what's up movie fans welcome back to
John Campea show the best damn movie
news do you know how the intro I mess up
the spoof mere observations you know
we're gonna talk about a few things
today all coming out of DC world so much
Snyder cut related news oh you gotta get
that keyword in there yes matter cut
Snyder Zack Snyder's justice like that
on YouTube subscribers get a notified
now we're gonna talk about this news
this rumor going around about Ben
Affleck returning as Batman possibly in
multiple movies I want to talk about I
didn't want to originally but then I
started looking into it and I was like
now I feel compelled to talk about it
the Ray Fisher I'm talkin about Joss
Whedon who's a reputation just seems to
be going is so uphill for killing the
game briefly want to cover a henry
cavill addressing the superman rumors
that sounds fun so there's there's a
whole bunch of DC things to talk about
but a couple things before we go into
that one we're probably gonna be doing a
live stream later today we normally do
those on Saturdays but tomorrow's fourth
of July so figured you know just move it
to today how the requested topic has
been like sequels we want to see so
probably gonna do that secondly at the
end of this video we're going to uncover
unbox this thing we already took it out
of the box but it's the special Columbia
classics disc set I can't wait to see
what's inside and what it all looks like
at the end for you cinema fans out there
it's like about the bed Affleck thing
first yeah it started some nice main
rumor going around it's Ben Affleck
assigned a batman contract for HBO max
there's multiple articles some people
have already reported on it in movie
news world this is old news okay but
let's break down this one article we
have in front of us
back in May saw the rumor first surfaced
from 4chan about Ben Affleck back as
Batman and now the light cast and
culture nerd YouTube channels claimed
the same the new info claims that Ben
Affleck has signed a new contract to
return his Batman and that Affleck will
be involved in additional appearances
related to HBO Max and Zack Snyder
Justice League movies all right so
here's what Taylor Murphy of the culture
nerd says Ben has I haven't seen the
video
this is how I imagine I don't even know
what he sounds like Ben has indeed sided
you contract and he is coming back the
official announcement is expected to
happen either a DC fandom ordering
justice Khan one of the two we're going
to get that announcement but it's going
to happen before September we're gonna
get the official announcement if we
couldn't get the Senators Batman it's
gonna be turning he goes to shoot down
the notion that Michael Keaton was
brought in to replace Ben Affleck as
Batman people thought that why would you
think that Pattinson being a replacement
as what is being created in DC
Multiverse they are bringing everybody
back this is plan this is a design
because of Zack this is a plan that
they're moving forward with I mean I
keep seeing it's a great time to be a DC
fan regarding why Ben Affleck agreed to
return as Batman it said because appliqu
will once again be in control of his
Batman so I think what this rumor is
going to support is that he will also be
able to do his Batman standalone project
to some extent right that's at least
what the rumor is communicating to me as
interestingly enough Geoff jaws has been
blamed as the reason why and I've heard
this before why Ben Affleck left the
Batman role as John's is said to have
caused interference with athletes
decisions involving the script this is
another reason why I wanted to talk
about the Ray Fisher thing because code
in line in addition Zack Snyder brought
Affleck on board as his choice for the
DCU Dark Knight incident Snyder left
Justice League athlete decided it wasn't
worth all the headaches to remain as
Batman Johns is also blamed for screwing
over Snyder and problems with Justice
League that he is the guy I was supposed
to save the DC he Murphy goes on to
explain I think a lot of people
misconstrued why he left in the first
place a lot of people will say Oh Ben
left because he almost killed himself in
the role I mean and might they might say
that because Ben Affleck said that oh so
you can't blame amateur usually in these
types of reports and stories sure actors
often as we even see kind of with Ray
Fisher to ascertain a certain extent I'm
not sure the timeline of one Ray Fisher
gave that thing that he retracted that
positive thing you said at Comic Con but
you know a lot of times actors and
actresses or directors who ever say
things but there's usually more that
happens behind the scenes you have to
give the Sanitary version for the public
exactly so Murphy goes on to say they
take it further than a really
essentially Ben took the role because of
Zach does that convince him sell them on
the pitch he loved the idea and he built
that loyalty to Zach mmm when Zach left
Ben still stayed behind he said I can
make this work I'll do this I'm still
producer than this I'm going to make it
happen but it started happening to him -
he started losing his control what he
wanted to do with the role he started
losing it and then he lost his interest
in it but he kept having sex with
Jennifer Garner constantly to take out
all that stress right and it didn't do
much and he realized that he kept going
down this path he wouldn't get what he
wanted he wouldn't get to do the role he
signed up for and it was just compromise
after compromise he didn't want to
compromise so he backed out but then the
magic happens that came back came back
in full force all the people that caused
the issues to begin with are gone zach
is back back is Zach Zach back the Zach
tech he's making his movie they pretty
much gave him a blank check to finish
these acts nighters Justice League so
giving that level of trust back to Zach
after the attack and going after his
rack Snyder was a huge moment for Ben
having the idea that zach is back and
you can't lack control of its project
before the project the Batman movie he
wanted to make and have Zach in his
corner that was enough to sell him of
the return ok so here's my thoughts
after reading all this and hearing
everything I don't think it's to this
extent yes he's gonna be doing
additional voiceover work maybe they
might need to film some stuff for the
Snyder cut I don't think it's to this
extent that they're talking about I
don't want that to come across though as
if I don't care for Ben Affleck to
return I love Ben Affleck's portrayal
the Batman says some he is the
definitive version there are a good good
amount of people who will claim he's the
definitive version of Batman the same
thing with Michael Keaton and Ben
Affleck here I think that they're doing
something weird with flashpoint that
they're gonna use it in some degree
where if the Snyder cup hands out well
that they'll want to somehow keep that a
little bit more linear with their
timeline as opposed to the one that we
didn't help I imagine that they might do
some type of alt like multiverse
bringing back some Batman
Michael Keaton for example Batman into
the bet something like flashpoint seems
like they're trying to do yeah I don't
think it's gonna be to the extent we're
gonna get Batman movies now with Ben
Affleck I feel like he's done with that
even with Zack Snyder back and I also
think it would just be confusing I could
be wrong these are all rumors at the end
of the day I could see Ben Affleck doing
a few more things with DC as Batman but
I don't think it's to the extent where
he is gonna be the lead in certain
projects or helming certain projects
same thing I think with Michael Keaton
like I could see Michael Keaton coming
back for the parents maybe Batman Beyond
but to the extent of like making in the
Nick Fury of the multiverse I don't buy
that and then you got rubber pants
Batman movie come this is too it's too
much that's the thing to me is I feel
like we're gonna all have to wait and
see what happens when the Snyder cut
finally drops I find these things funny
these these rumors are interesting to me
because especially with WB you know HBO
I trust more than WB generally but WB
you know makes a lot of decisions and
then changes them very quickly part of
this will definitely depend on how
successful the Snider cut is how good it
is the thing I could see coming out of
this is like if all the stars align this
equates to them kind of healing the
timeline for both the creatives and the
fans of Zack Snyder's vision maybe we
can see something like a watchman style
Ben Affleck HBO Batman miniseries yeah
that's something that's yeah not a movie
that's gonna be like for people who
aren't following this avidly why are
there two random Batman movies what
happened to this old timeline what this
is all pointing to is that this will be
for HBO max for some reason I'm just not
buying HBO max would actually love to do
it were you on the big screen you got
the Robert Pattinson movies and then you
have here on HBO max the Ben Affleck
Batman whatever yeah these are our
Falcon and Winter Soldier
these are Wanda visions you know like II
see that actually sounds cool to me I'm
not gonna lie like if they do that I
would be very excited I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you and be like just because I
don't believe it means I want to be
right like that's not the case if they
come out of like it's confirmed they're
doing it oh that's so cool
right now I'm not buying it well yeah
maybe able to do it in a harmonious way
where it does right by all look like the
creatives - yeah that it's not like hey
I know we're doing this thing now with
Matt Reeves and all you other guys since
the wake of this but we're gonna go back
WB needs to demonstrate a certain amount
of leadership and figuring out how to
solidify these things so that they can
all thrive and shine in their best
arenas I think well the funny thing is
with enough demand from DC fans and
anything I mean and that's the other
thing too is is it's like DC Christmas
Day right now we're like the Snider cut
broke this wall down where now it's like
oh there's so many possibilities maybe
there will be an A or cut maybe Ben
Affleck ooh come back I have to imagine
that the shotgun blast some of the
targets will hit I just don't know which
ones I feel like half the news we're
hearing is probably not gonna come to
fruition but we'll see I mean but do you
guys want this do you guys want a Ben
Affleck whatever I didn't make it clear
exactly what it is they're gonna be
doing when you want bat slack back flick
but a miniseries or if he gets to do his
own movie for hmm it seems like HBO max
might have noticed people and they
really care about us now that wouldn't
that be funny the thing that like one of
the key ingredients to driving the DC
you into the ground initially will say
HBO max which would be cool I don't know
maybe maybe they'll have more freedom
there too because it seems like working
with Jeff Johnson and the other WB folks
has been kind of constrictive so let's
move on here people um okay let's talk
about this ray Fisher news all right it
started off on June 29 through a Fisher
said this I'll just play the footage for
you guys a good person to come in and
clean up and finish up for him
I'm required to see this that was
convincing do it we said the thing we
needed and honestly you know they could
just be reading into this because of the
fact that he's saying he retracts this
and we could be reading into the body
language and stuff we could be right now
that's how it reads that ok I'd like to
take a moment to forcefully retract
every bit of this statement right yeah
when I first saw that I I was sitting
there going weird really cuz like
everyone was at least like we adjusted
as did his best well I mean that's what
they have to say right I guess a Fisher
went on to say later on Joss Whedon's
onset treatment of the casting for
justice Lee was gross abusive
unprofessional and completely
unacceptable he was enabled in many ways
by Geoff Johns and John burg
accountability / entertainment this just
bleeds like if anything Hey
the main takeaway is for me what exactly
was he like on set like I'm not gonna
deny ray Fisher hearing the kind of
everything that's come out about Joss
Whedon as of late yeah it's easy to
believe if he was someone different on
set and if he was imagine I kind of
emotionally in verbally abusive
individual right yeah I don't know what
and I don't want to go into like here's
what he did because I don't know and
it's not made clear here you can look up
any rumors you want about that but yeah
I mean he's got he's received a few
black eyes lately for that as well as
some not I don't know to what extent but
sexual misconduct it sucks and that
actually this goes to further support
you know wanting the Snyder cut anything
well yeah that's like a moral angle to
it yeah exactly the moral angle and with
geoff johns as well because for a long
time that's kind of just been in like
certain people who get two scoops on
things and hearing about geoff johns but
for ray Fisher cyborg to come out and
say geoff johns also that just further
supports that
what we brought up in the van athlete
portion of this video Jeff Johnson just
seems like a horrible or stuck in a
particular way that is not tenable for a
community like this ever like nothing
but bad things about that guy in like
the last six months to a year is what
I'm constantly hearing about and this
sucks
Zack Snyder had to step away they're
very excited for it this was gonna be
ray Fisher's big break and then for
everyone involved to have Zack center
step away then you get this other
director to come in who's supposed to
save the day and then he ends up being
this director who apparently was a real
villain yeah who was the Steppenwolf on
say yeah he was a dark side of it all
yeah which sucks it's terrible what
compelled me a little bit more to talk
about this as an alan tudyk chimed in
who's worked for joss whedon how many
things who said wasn't there but I have
known jaws for 17 years I honestly can't
even imagine it and I have a pretty good
imagination and my thoughts when he said
that there's a tweet he said later that
I will I'll bring up but it's important
what he said here because my initial
reaction was well dude you weren't there
you know yeah and it's that kind of
thing of you know when we get mad at
canceled culture when we get mad at why
are you judging someone off their past
from years ago when they're different
person today and they've made
reconciliation or whatever you know that
argument now you can flip that though it
doesn't matter if he was good on that
set he could have been a terrible per
who he is today could be a different be
Divya Newman being yeah it doesn't
matter what your past experience was you
weren't there on set and this is a
different project different times he's
been through a lot of different
experiences since then to come out and
defend him in a way is yeah a messed up
or IP or at least yet I throw that like
I don't think it's an entirely unfair
idea to throw out but to do it without
an additional qualifier like to do it in
a way that requires you to go back and
post something else later to qualify it
I think is yeah not quite the right look
later on is it some Twitter user named
I'm a frog said you weren't there and
the story I found this when I was like
gathering strange video and alan tudyk
said true i shouldn't deny another
person's experience if i wasn't there
it's ignorant i've my experiences in and
out of work with jaws were he had
been kind and supportive brilliant and
funny is a hard-worker taskmaster
compassionate if unconventional dancer
respect I get caught up in semantics
here I can get caught up in
technicalities yes he he did own up in
the first three sentences are you really
hung up yeah wanted to get all technical
about communication it's cuz I'm like
well you say it there but you go really
in the depth of why you don't believe
Johnson it's kind of that thing of you
you could have just said like it's
ignorant but yeah you know he doesn't
save the word but but it reads that way
yeah you know there I just don't think
this holds any weight or validity and
some people a lot of people have
actually got it on him about dude you
weren't there yeah you you don't have a
say in this like I get how he's feeling
but this is not the kind of thing you
want to come out and be like like of
course if you're friends with somebody
if you've known them for years if
they're partially responsible for many
of your big opportunities like yeah it's
reasonable to feel these things but ya
don't come out and and have that because
like that's your personal thing that's
for you that's for you in him and
whatever sites you know for the people
out there it does kind of show support
in a weird direction and I know that
times are very volatile and people do
tend to dog pile for some good reason
but yeah it's the kind of thing where I
think he should hone in on the first
part of the sentiment because he might
be about to be in for a rude awakening
yeah I feel like these days you can't
deny that possibility to yourself I like
Alan Tudyk he's a hilarious actor actor
and Joss Whedon has made some great
things at the end of the day it's like
if if a fish ray Fisher had this first
personal first-hand experience with him
I don't see other Justice League members
coming to the front and being like Ray's
now I've seen a lot of them come in
support of the sniper good yeah pretty
much and before it seemed like the way
the film turned out yeah this like you
said earlier the holds a moral weight to
it now I can imagine even more now why
the actors back Zack Snyder somewhat
because the one thing that I've
constantly here whatever critical
reception there has been to the Zack
Snyder films the actors have always
loved like every actor has talked so
positively about the kind of human Zack
is
yeah yeah that's important well yeah I
mean as much as I can get cynical and
and stuff about some of the content of
his movies I mean that is one of the
things that matters and in life in the
world when you remember that you know
these movies are made by people for
people you know you should be able to
have a decently good or at least you
know functional healthy time on set and
yeah you know that's part of the key to
keeping yourself working for a long time
is to run a place where people like you
and people want to show up for you it's
gotta burn especially if they love dak
Schneider and working with him already
you can tell Zacks not really cares
about the project then he has a personal
tragedy and then the film falls into the
hands of somebody who is you know not
conducting even with the baseline of
respect from what it sounds like like
yeah I can definitely see why anyone
involved with that movie would what at
certain point come out and just be fiery
sort of we need to go back to the old
version I mean before I got perverted I
got a minute like it's do we need to
know the specifics probably not do I
really really want to know the specifics
now yeah I do everybody when you say
they're serious I think we ought to know
it sounds serious he's saying his onset
treatment of both cast and crew was
gross abusive unprofessional yeah and
depending on the extent of that should
this man be allowed he should be allowed
to make my stuff should he be held to
his highest standard even people need to
be held accountable and that's the whole
point I'm not saying because of this one
statement we should go out there and I
mean Johnson he's got a lot working
against him yeah which is ironic
especially given the the feminist mantle
he was builds his reputation upon I do
think I would like to know the specifics
I I would at this point it's become such
a saga and honestly it's weird it's like
he kind of seems to Joss Whedon's thing
kind of seems to pass under the radar a
little bit and this like there was the
sexual misconduct allegations and such
yet this obviously has gotten way more
of a spotlight yeah yeah weird
because I mean he's got I mean he he's
had a reputation for being a philanderer
at best I mean I don't know yet if he's
done any like assaulting ended like
truly illegal variety but yeah I mean he
has a pretty poor reputation now in
terms of just his sexual conduct using
that position of power to you know
entice people just the other day I
didn't realize this but they said like a
stuntwoman filled in for a gal gadot
because she didn't want to do the part
where Ezra Miller falls on her chest or
whatever yeah like there's there's a lot
there that I wouldn't be surprised to
hear there's more to I don't know the
guy and I haven't followed his personal
life deeply over the years but from
things I've heard even from people who
have you know had friends work with him
I've heard it's not as shiny as it looks
from the outside well guys what do you
think of this story your thoughts yeah
in the last bit of news
henry cavill he opened up about the
superman rumors he said the rumors get
wilder and wilder by the day the amount
of speculation the stuff I read on the
Internet is extraordinary and sometimes
frustrating it's when you see people
stating stuff it's fact like no that's
not the case that hasn't happened and
that conversation isn't happening but
the important thing is that people are
excited about it I think it's important
to be excited by a character like
Superman Superman is a fantastic
character if people are chatting about
it and even if they're making stuff up
it's okay because that means they want
to see the character again in an ideal
world I would absolutely love to play
the character again dude this is why we
have this not good this is like more
possible than ever before and of all the
things I would actually be really
excited to see him come back to Superman
I mean we all want it I only want to
talk briefly about this I remember when
Henry Cavill was like honestly I want to
just move past this not Erica you know
I'm trying to move forward yeah he said
never insane that like on video
interviews I'm saying but this idea of
like championing for him to return it's
like this is also interesting because
there's been so many different rumors
and he's even going out there saying
that this conversations that are
reportedly happening to have just
flat-out aren't sure what happened yeah
and maybe some stuff actually has
happened or a lot of stuff has been
misconstrued so every bit of rumor or a
news report that comes out has to be
taken with a grain of salt but I think
the Snyder cut is evidence and the fact
that not everything is just a rumor and
not everything is just speculation
that a lot of the times
they're like that article in the
Schneider cut that of was a variety put
out or Holly reporting hammer which one
go whichever one they put out was like
yeah he's going to come back him chiming
in on this obviously he's gonna be asked
about it and the cool thing is he's not
saying I want to move past this I want
to before he wants to keep on doing it
if any studio is going to be listening
to what the fans want it's gonna be the
people behind EC obviously yeah they're
listening
henry cavill is gonna come back
undoubtably oh yeah so not everything
i've we're gonna hear it is 100% true or
not but i think let's face it he's gonna
come because now you like he's it's
gotten to the point and it's got to be
moving for him like even if he was
genuinely ready to move past it before
like when the snyder cut became real i
got to imagine that that's the moment
where it probably hits you like there
are a lot of people who really care
about my portrayal Superman you know and
and even for me like I haven't loved his
Superman but I am still here rooting for
like yeah I would love to see a great
Superman story with Henry Cavill in it
so you know what however that becomes
possible even if it's just another
appearance or something I gotta imagine
yeah he will get his chance even more
than Ben Affleck I think he has been
kind of slighted by this process all
right yes well good for Henry Cavill
yeah he's got a good adjusted way of
looking at things
well guys leave your thoughts down below
on all these news I love talking about
all the DC stuff except for DC fan and
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
let's see what's in this box
sooo so this is a box sent over to us by
Columbia Pictures it's a six of their
most iconic films and what I actually
learned is the two of these films a
Jerry Maguire and a league of their own
were voted in by fans so yeah like over
30,000 votes it's the first time any of
these films have been released in 4k
Ultra HD if you're our film fan if
you're somebody who's into cinema in
general these are some classic films and
you'll be able to see them in the
highest definition possible it also
comes with as you're about to see a
really great a hardcover 80 page book
and also a host of special features look
at that ya got a host of special
features and archival footage new
special features it's
really easy to use you got all the DVDs
in here they come like this on my on my
left and right hand right here the
movies that you got are mr. Smith goes
to Washington Lawrence of Arabia dr.
Strangelove Jerry Maguire a league of
their own and Gandhi all Ultra HD and
blu-ray and then this is the
aforementioned this is the special book
that comes with it it's hardcover 80
pages of historical information behind
the scenes looks at these films at the
industry at the time it's pretty sweet
like I said if you're into Hollywood
history if you're in a classic cinema
and if you love the Columbia classics
featured in this box it's definitely
something worth checking out because
that's the only place you can get these
films in 4k Ultra HD thank you so much
to Columbia and Sony for sending this
over pick up your own today thank you
guys look at that beautiful I'll get a
sword and we'll cut this box in half you
take half home with you I'll take Gandhi
a league of their own and Jerry Maguire
you can keep the older thank you think
jams Sony and Columbia you guys are
gifting us this holiday season fourth of
July I will be watching I guess a league
of their own watch mr. Smith goes to
Washington
I don't know leaguer their own yeah
that's probably more more field than
capital for Gandhi dr. Strangelove guys
I'm stalling the video subscribe hit
that like button comment subscribe to
the more falling alright see you guys